alors depuis la création de l'humanité
l'homme a toujours essayé de d'évoluer
au fur et à mesure du temps il ya 3500
ans à peine
l'homme inventé la roue aujourd'hui nous
sommes capables d'opérer un coeur à
distance ou bien même de programmer un
robot qui est capable de recoudre un
poids d'un patient sans même l'ouvrir
et pourtant malgré toutes ces évolutions
il ya un postulat qui n'a jamais bougé
dans le temps une constance c'est le
clivage qu'il ya entre les écoles de
commerce et les cycles d'innovation
on a beau tout faire vous êtes toujours
autant convivialité et j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi alors je suis pas un
grand économiste je ne suis pas un grand
scientifique et je pense que mes
connaissances et mon expérience aussi
vous prouvez lettres en lumière que vos
deux univers deux surfaces différentes
salles bien au contraire il ya plein de
points qui vont justement à la rencontre
de ces demandes et c'est ce que je vais
vous présenter aujourd'hui je vous
présente et l'interdépendance de
l'économie dans l'innovation
alors ayons déjà encore l'innovation est
au service de la finance
le premier terme qui indique tout ça
assez clairement c'est le terme de
phitek tout simplement la contraction
entre terme finances et technologies
effectivement c'est ce qui vous permet
de payer par mobile ou bien de faire une
cagnotte pour vos amis pour l'achat des
cadeaux d'anniversaire tient à main
levée activement le parmi vous qui
utilisent si la majorité est grande
majorité cette statistique elle est loin
d'être ordinaire bien au contraire il ya
quelques années personne aurait levé la
main entre cette table effectivement
depuis 2015 à peu près il ya eu un
énorme essor médiatique signer ce terme
n'est pas du tout nouveau au contraire
il a été créé en 1972 il ya 47 ans
personne n'avait jamais entendu ce terme
avant effectivement il ya un grand
engouement aujourd'hui par rapport à ça
vous laisse imaginer et donc la
croissance exponentielle que ça peut
représenter un autre de impôts si qui
est assez parlant c'est le chèque
aujourd'hui plus personne ne cachait
d'ailleurs entre 2010 et 2016
l'émission des chèques a diminué de 32%
alors que le chèque a été quand même
inventé en 1865
donc ça pose un vrai problème de départ
c'est à dire quel va être le paiement de
demain finalement certains pensent au
paiement biométrique
d'autres pensent aussi pouvoir acheter
sa baguette de pain avec un 7 10 tout
simplement
stay tuned blague amazon a développé
tout ça où on a déposé deux brevets un
exemple aussi qui est assez marquant
c'est l'arrivée du bitcoin aussi dans le
monde aujourd'hui le bitcoin il ya 52
milliards d'euros qui circulent à
travers le monde un big oil titre
d'exemple par exemple le bitcoin sa
création il ya à peu près 10 ans valait
0 00 08 dollars en janvier
il valait 4040 dollars je vous laisse
imaginer à quelle vitesse tout ça va on
pense un petit peu que c'est la science
fiction mais bien au contraire il ya un
exemple qui est assez répandu aussi au
venezuela le très célèbre président ex
président nicholas maduro a fait parler
de lui aussi en créant sa propre crypto
monnaie qui est le petro qui est indexé
sur le prix du baril de pétrole opep de
monnaies qui est obligatoire au même
titre que l'euro en france et qui sert
tout simplement à limiter la
crise au venezuela alors j'aime à penser
quand même que cette dépendance ne va
pas que dans un sens il ya aussi des
éléments qui prouvent que la finance
c'est aussi au coeur de l'innovation
parce que je présentais maintenant la
première exemple qui me vient en tête de
par ma profession s'élèvent ces pays
les fonds communs de placement dans
l'innovation avant de vous expliquer
qu'est ce que ces pays pardon j'ai
d'abord vous expliquer quel est le rôle
de l'impôt en france très important
l'impôt il a trois grandes valeurs en
france il a trois grand rôle il a la
collecte des recettes pour financer les
dépenses publiques
il ya aussi la régulation des richesses
en transe la régulation des patrimoines
il ya un troisième élément qui est très
important on va se concentrer là dessus
c'est l'application de la politique
fiscale est effectivement quand on
consomme quand on épargne quand on a des
styles au sens de l'état qui arrange
l'état à l'état nous récompense par le
biais de la fiscalité en faisant des
déductions des réductions des crédits
d'impôts
c'est là où lève ces pays rentrent en
jeu dans l'innovation si effectivement
les abcès pays dont ces fonds communs de
placement dans l'innovation c'est des
sociétés de gestion qui donc simplement
vont collecter l'argent des
investisseurs pour l'or redistribués
dans des start up des pme françaises qui
sont imputés innovant est bon pour vous
donner un exemple assez clair g1 et
clients imaginant qu'ils aient besoin de
d'avoir des revenus complémentaires qui
aimerait bien travailler à l'innovation
et qui aimeraient aussi combattre sa
fiscalité
c'est là où ces pays vont intervenir
tout simplement parce que ça un
investissement de 5000 euros
dans ce cadre edf cpi va permettre une
économie d'impôt de 900 euros pour mon
client donc vous ça vous concerne aussi
puisque c'est vous les ce qu'ils vont
faire l'innovation demain c'est vous qui
allez participer à ça vous allez
comprendre que à ce moment là les points
communs de placement à l'innovation ont
toute leur importance
un autre exemple qui me vient en tête
aussi c'est le crowdfunding dame qu'on
attendait pas du tout qui as est revenu
dans l'actualité le financement
participatif c'est un moyen de
contourner les banques pour pouvoir
avoir des levées de fonds tout
simplement
il existe des plateformes sur internet
où on a différents projets et
l'internaute a le choix de pouvoir
comment amener sa participation une
petite somme d'argent tout simplement
avec ou sans rétribution pour participer
à un projet ça permet de collecter la
pas mal d'argent pour celle des projets
qui sont très ambitieux effectivement ça
permet de contourner les banques parce
que dans le cadre de l'innovation c'est
très très compliqué de pouvoir trouver
un financement
ce sont des projets qui sont extrêmement
ambitieux et on voit pas trop les
retombées économiques sur le court terme
or quand on fait un crédit pour avoir un
financement il ya tout intérêt à bien
analyser la capacité de remboursement de
son client pour être sûr que puisse
simplement être en capacité de
rembourser l'emprunt qui a nécessité le
crowdfunding justement permis d'éviter
ça permet ainsi d levée de fonds qui
sont incroyables alors effectivement
dans l'innovation il ya beaucoup de
choses qui rentrent en jeu et que c'est
quelque chose qui est encore assez
récent on a peu d'éléments aujourd'hui
et qui qui montre un exemple concret
j'en ai choisi quelques uns
normalement ils sont orientés vers la
culture geek c'est quelque chose qui est
très numérique mais on retrouve plus
trop cette logique aujourd'hui je vous
donnais deux exemples qui sont vraiment
en sont diamétralement opposées pour
vous montrer un exemple le site français
par exemple recueilli 325 1000 euros
grâce au crowdfunding aussi dans un
autre registre il ya un bateau qui a été
donc financé quand ce train de forniquer
ça tout simplement à récupérer les
réfugiés donc qui sont échouées sur la
mer méditerranée
joli projet qui réduit quand même la
somme de 275 mille euros pour que ça
soit portée à bien aujourd'hui c'est
vous qui avez participé à ce financement
là c'est vous qui allez mettre vos
projets en place ça c'est pas très
compliqué il faut pas faire un business
plan incroyable il suffit juste d'avoir
une connexion internet avoir un écran un
clavier accessoirement une souris à part
cela vous pourrez envisager de lever des
fonds ce que je vous souhaite me dan
également que j'ai voulu me présenter
c'est aussi le rôle des banques
il sort un petit peu de son domaine d
expertise pour vous aider à vous
effectivement les banques ont compris
que vous êtes les google et apple de
demain c'est évident et donc elle vous
mettre à disposition tous les outils
tous les accessoires nécessaires pour
que vous puissiez mener vos projets à
bien monsieur développer une relation de
confiance avec eux lance notamment une
banque qui a construit
un bâtiment de 4500 m² juste pour vous
pour les futurs et innovant de ce pays
où ils peuvent simplement aller
travailler c'est en libre accès ils
peuvent aussi rencontrer des partenaires
qui les aideront simplement a lancé
leurs bottes et le projet c'est
justement qu'ils puissent se développer
tous ensemble et qu'ils puissent la
recevoir l'accompagnement qui est très
difficile à obtenir aujourd'hui
effectivement j'avais quelques minutes
pour vous présenter tout ça d exemple on
aurait pu trouver plein je construis mon
message vous l'avez cammas est bien
saisi dans l'ensemble à dire qui est
effectivement il ya une dépendance une
interdépendance entre l'économie et
l'innovation qui aujourd'hui évidente et
vous avez exactement les mêmes
problématiques que les costumes cravates
que vous pouvez voir vous allez bien
danny gray alors s'il vous plaît soyez
gentils avec le problème merci votre
attention
[Applaudissements]